I wanted Jack Straw the former labor
cabinet member who served in various
roles including Home Secretary and
foreign secretary alongside David Miller
and welcome to you indeed and the
alongside many others was it like I
think it's about the first time about 50
years you haven't had a parliamentary
part was it well the first day it's
great and I've been able to see my wife
during the day so it's a interesting
sense of liberation but of course I care
about the Labour Party very much indeed
and grieve for this completely
unnecessary there disaster that
afflicted us self inflicted last
Thursday night your son candidate he
didn't get elected one of the victims of
that I mean when you say a
self-inflicted disaster what do you mean
what I mean by that is is that the party
made in my view the wrong decision about
who should be leader four and a half
years ago and Ed Miliband is a man of
considerable talent humanity very bright
indeed but his pitch was incorrect when
he stood for party leader and he then
compounded that in two respects
one by not understanding that you can
only talk about the future if you've
dealt with the past and in the jargon
the electorate will not give you
permission to talk about the future
unless you have defended the past we had
a very good record we can get rid
everything right but but instead I'm
afraid ed allowed the the narrative
conservatives narratives that we
completely screwed up the economy to
become a part of the sort of
conventional wisdom and then he seemed
to ass to New Labour big reasons I never
could never understand what New Labour
was about was ensuring that the Labour
Party went for the middle ground as well
as fallen it will allow us go through
that so you do you feel that post credit
crunch post 2010 that the Labour Party
should have said as Liam Bern put it
that you did may not have caused the
crisis but you made it worse because you
did overspend in the years no I don't
know I know I don't and I
I think that what the truth is that
between 1997 and 2008 although the
Conservatives haften puff they broadly
supported our spending plan that's true
too but without sight you might admit
are you overspent well yes but one I'm
not going to admit since the
Conservatives supported our spending
powers when I was getting around so was
my son with a copy of the time to the
3rd September 2007 in which George
Osborne wrote a sign piece saying we're
not going to cut we're going to support
the labor spending plans and I said to
Ed a number of times before why don't
you use that but there was this kind of
reluctance to I mean of course with the
benefit of hindsight we could have made
up that there's different decisions you
can always do that but overall we got
the broad economic policy correct
between 2007 and 1997 to 2007 I mean on
the scale of the borrowing that we had
we undertook between 2008 and 2010 the
question for the Conservatives were what
the devil would they have done a new
Gallup I don't mean you mentioned that
he disassociated himself from new labor
that was largely because of the
unpopularity and worse of Iraq and
Afghanistan well I don't think I mean I
thought for the most of the British
public they had moved on from Iraq and
Afghanistan and new labour was not about
Iraq and Afghanistan I mean no that's
what people remember there I don't think
they do I think that that no one could
have anticipated 9/11 Afghanistan was
entirely justified I'm happy to justify
Iraq but I won't do that that now but
know what new label was about that was
about reaching out to aspirational
people I mean and not and under and this
was also part of the error of the what
amounted to our pitch between 2010 and
this election being too metropolitan we
have a great bedrock in the metropolitan
areas but we don't in what's been
described as post-industrial Brit many
parts of East Lancashire the West
Midlands coastal areas and we're not
connecting with people previously
regarded as working-class who themselves
are there
aspirational what about the future now
how do you see the choice about the
leadership well one thing I'm clear
about with the benefit of a lot of
experience is and I don't know what
decision the parliamentary Labour Party
is making is they need to get on with
this they the idea that the party would
be in a better position by having of six
months campaign that the three months I
think is not correct
we had an elongated period for an
election last time and that simply
allowed the Conservatives to frame as I
understand it they haven't decided yet
what the hell is that but who would you
fancy as leader I'm because the runners
and riders arm and out I'm not going to
make my own new little person
yes but somebody somebody yeah
absolutely they can call themselves
something else and I was never Terry
bothered about the label it's it's it's
what's in the tin rather than what's on
the tin that ultimately matters and
that's what I think was not understood
about the imports of new labour it was
in the tin that we had a different set
of policies from those which we've
offered in the 1980s and the early 90s
where I'm afraid that disastrous results
and I don't want the party to make the
same mistakes again and what we need to
do is not that difficult but we failed
to do it last time